jetzt öffnen sich langsam auch
außereuropäische länder und da kann es
oft sein dass man zwar reisen darf aber
dass man einen gültigen negativen krohn
attest vorlegen muss und mein kollege
michael quandt ist uns aus dubai
zugeschaltet und er hat das miterlebt
hat den auch bezahlt micha wie geht das
wie bekomme ich am flughafen einen
corona test ja hallo frank das ging in
frankfurt relativ einfach ich bin in das
abstrich zentrum in der nähe vom
fernbahnhof am frankfurter flughafen
gegangen
dort habe ich einen abstrich gemacht und
habe das ergebnis später per e-mail als
zugeschickt bekommen konnte es als pdf
auf meinem smartphone laden und habe
geglaubt damit ist alles gut war aber in
der tat am ende etwas anders wenn ja wie
wir ja also ich habe für diesen test der
kostet 59 euro dann kriegt bei denen
zwei bis drei stunden in sechs bis acht
stunden für 139 euro ab nächste woche in
zwei bis drei stunden
und als sich dann als ich dann in dubai
eingereist im stellte man fest dass
dieser test nicht anerkannt wird weil er
nicht auf papier ausgedruckt war hätte
ich ihn auf papier ausgedruckt gehabt
hätten ihnen die behörden anerkannt als
pdf auf dem iphone nicht und so musste
ich dann nach der einreise noch einmal
einen abstrich in dubai am flughafen
machen lassen der dann allerdings
kostenlos ist das ergebnis kommt dann
wenige stunden oder am nächsten morgen
dann per sms auf dein smartphone und das
ist dann gültig ja also ich hoffe bei
dir ist da alles im lack tatsächlich ist
das ja nicht nur ein problem was
urlauber in richtung dubai angeht ich
vermute auch wenn man nach kanada reisen
da vielleicht auch wieder usa vielleicht
asien da wird man immer einen koran
attest vorlegen müssen
das erhöht natürlich auch letztlich die
reisekosten du hast es ja ab 59 euro
finde ich jetzt noch so einigermaßen
verschmerzbar aber wenn es halt dann
über 100 kostet dann würde ich mir
natürlich dann die reise auch überlegen
ich nehme an kempkens dazu
wie ist das wie kann ich sicher sein
dass dieser test dann auch vor ort
anerkannt wird also mich erkannte er
sich wirklich mitreißen hervorragend
auskennt ist dann möglicherweise auch
schlecht beraten gewesen
ja das ist wahrscheinlich auch so zu
sein denn der reiseveranstalter jetzt
hinweise gibt wie das eben zu
bewerkstelligen ist also wie man diesen
nachweis führt dann kann man sich
vertragsrechtlich auch darauf verlassen
und wenn das hinterher nicht reicht hat
man ein schadenersatzanspruch und das
ist auch eine vertragliche nebenpflicht
also der reiseveranstalter muss schon
auch darüber aufklären was bei der
einreise erforderlich ist und das ändert
sich natürlich ständig das müssen wir
natürlich auch ehrlicherweise sagen und
der reiseveranstalter ist also gefragt
da auch immer nachzujustieren
das heißt wenn er feststellt das ändert
sich jetzt also wie wir es
beispielsweise aus diesem bericht gerade
gehört haben dass also es heißt es muss
ausgedruckt werden dann muss der
reiseveranstalter das natürlich in
seiner in sein portfolio aufnehmen das
eben schreibt ihr müsst nicht nur
nachweis haben sondern ihr müsst ihn
eben ausdrucken und das muss man dann
eben tatsächlich auch wissen und wenn
das unterlassen wird hat man ein
schadenersatzanspruch ansonsten muss man
als reisender natürlich selbst dafür
sorge leisten dass man überhaupt
einreisen darf also das ist im grunde
genommen so ein bisschen wechselspielen
mich hat man muss das rad dann
funktioniert das ist ja auch vieles
neuland wahrscheinlich in frankfurt gibt
es wahrscheinlich auch eine stelle die
diesen corona test anbietet hat es was
sie dir sicher das klappt oder dachtest
du ja gucken wir mal nein ich war mir
hundertprozentig sicher dass das klappt
dann muss er zur verteidigung des
abstiegs zentrums auf und dubai sagen
dass diese regelung gestern morgen in
dubai in kraft getreten ist und sich
einfach bis dahin bis zu meiner abreise
nicht nach deutschland durch gesprochen
hat ansonst ich bin fest davon
ausgegangen dass das auf dem iphone als
pdf gültig ist
der test an sich dann aber hier am
airport in dubai ging innerhalb von zwei
minuten vonstatten das war sehr sehr
schnell noch eine ein formular ausfüllen
mit kontaktdaten und dann war man auch
ruckzuck bei der gepäckausgabe also der
zeitliche aufwand hier war gleich null
und das ergebnis kommt per sms
problemlos und das bei am ende war es
ein guter service und sagt noch mal ganz
schnell du stehst da schon an einem pool
in einer hotelanlage gibt es der chor
ohne einschränkung wie zeigt sich du bei
dir
naja also hier gelten schon in dubai
immer noch erhaltlich strenge kohler
regeln außerhalb der gebäude auch auf
der straße gilt eine masken pflicht in
taxen bussen öffentliche verkehrsmitteln
sowieso ihrem hotel wenn man durch die
gänge geht muss auch maske getragen
werden im hotel selber ist die zahl am
pult am strand sind die zahl der ligen
deutlich verringert worden die abstände
sind vergrößert worden
in den restaurants gibt es weniger
weniger tische überall findet man
abstands markierungen auf dem boden um
das social dating einzuhalten an jeder
ecke sind desinfektion spender und sehr
nettes detail es gibt hier keine
speisekarte mehr sondern auf jeden tisch
sein ein qr-code den fotografiert man
mit seinem smartphone und hat dann in
sekundenschnelle die speisekarte auf
seinem smartphone
auch das macht man um halt kontakte
kontaktflächen zu minimieren
absolut vielen dank ich ja noch eine
frage an amt am kempkens wie ist das
denn wenn ich quasi losfliegen will
vielleicht gibt es ja sogar auch in
europa irgendwann mal region wo ich
vielleicht einen negativen corona attest
vorlegen muss und an meinem flughafen da
gibt es gar keine möglichkeit diesen
corona test zu machen wie verhalte ich
mich da
also das kann durchaus passieren weil
die lage ja nach wie vor total dynamisch
ist es gibt ja immer wieder so hot spots
und dann wird nachjustiert das kann also
durchaus passieren und da muss man
wirklich ganz up to date sein man muss
wirklich immer ständig wie du es gerade
gehört haben es wurde ja erst einen tag
vorher wurde der wurde ja nur etwas
verändert und eine kleinigkeit verändert
die sofort große auswirkung hat hier
über die möglichkeit dass es eben dann
ganz schnell auch anderweitig geregelt
werden konnte
aber das können wir nicht immer erwarten
also das ist wirklich eine schwierige
situation der veranstalter muss
hinweisen vertragsrechtlich ich muss mir
als reisender auch gedanken machen und
letztlich ist aber die frage des aus der
ausreise und der einreise ist im grunde
genommen auch sache des reisenden also
man kann sich nicht immer nur auf den
veranstalter verlassen der muss
hinweisen die voraussetzung muss ich
aber selber schaffen und wenn es
tatsächlich zu einer kurzfristigen
änderung kommt und ich nicht anreisen
kann
dann kriege ich in aller regel das geld
zurück aber beispielsweise keinen
schadenersatzanspruch wenn ich dann
umbuchen muss er wirklich interessant
wie ist das bei leuten die mit dem
internet nicht so gut umgehen können
die rede war von qr codes und ich habe
den crooner ist auf meinem handy
wenn ich zum beispiel jetzt keine
roaminggebühren riskieren will bin ich
dann darauf angewiesen oder geht es auch
für leute einfach nur auf dem papier
na ja das ist schon schwer man muss
schon sagen gerade jetzt andrea so die
die elektronische zeit kriegt ja so ein
totalen schub so dass man nicht einfach
so sagen kann es gibt immer so
mitverschulden das im gesetz auch so
verankert das heißt wenn ich selber an
einem schaden vorwerfbar irgendwie
mitgewirkt habe da muss ich zumindest
ein teil selber übernehmen und das ist
beispielsweise dann der fall wenn ich so
allgemein zugängliche quellen
diese qr-codes beispielsweise oder
internet wenn ich die nichtnutzer aus
welchen gründen auch immer
dann kann es durchaus sein dass ich
einen teil meines schaden selber
bezahlen muss das heißt man muss schon
die aktuellen informationsquellen
tatsächlich auch nutzt man kann also
nicht sagen habe ich jetzt keine lust zu
lesen der zeitung das reicht nicht aus
wichtige information von arndt kempgens
vielen dank michael grüße nach dubai und
bis zum nächsten mal